[Music]
it's red carpet official yep kim
kardashian and pete davidson make their
red carpet debut at the white house
correspondents dinner on saturday
evening kim stunned in a silver dress by
balenciaga couture when it comes to
jewelry the kardashian star kept it
simple but bold with diamond stud
earrings and a ring by lorraine schwartz
the 41 year old allowed the dress to do
the talking by rocking a soft glam
makeup look and wearing her hair long
wet and wavy pete looked dapper by her
side and wore a prada shoot with a
skinny tie while coordinating with a
pair of dark black sunglasses and
classic black and white vans why not
pete and kim kept their pda moments on
the carpet subtle from staring into each
other's eyes to pete resting his hands
on ken's lower back and here's another
moment where the comedian is captured
whispering in the skim's founder's ear i
love that
known as the nerd prom pete and kim were
in good company at the white house
correspondents dinner as president joe
biden first lady dr jill biden and more
were in attendance trevor noah hosted
the event which made its official return
after a two-year hiatus on the red
carpet et spoke with gail king and drew
barrymore who gave their reaction to
seeing kim and pete together at the
dinner we thought keat
it's so exciting
what would we have done without benefir
you know now we combined everybody's
names and it's exciting i mean
we both love pop culture and
i i think it's great she's here don't
you i think it's very thin together i
think it's fun kim and pete's red carpet
debut comes before what is expected to
be a moment for the couple at the met
gala and it comes after the comedian
showed his girlfriend some support in
court on thursday during the closing
arguments in blac chyna's lawsuit
against the kardashian family according
to reports pete hugged kim and her
sister in court briefly and was spotted
sharing a kiss with her in the hallway
after closing arguments had ended
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him last month the
source told e.t that quote kim is head
over heels for pete and when we spoke
with her she revealed what it is about
him that has her falling
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing that's the goal
is finding someone to do nothing with
it's the best because you can do
everything with totally but it's crazy
to be distracted with people you can be
with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing
[Music]